the cost of building the largest and
most luxurious ocean liner on earth is
phenomenal four times the budget for the
film Titanic success hinges on the
finished ship producing enough money to
be profitable you're not gonna make a
you know nearly billion dollar
investment unless you can get a return
on your investment that comes down to
one thing
space the ship must be big enough to
carry more fare-paying passengers than
any other liner in history and to draw
the crowds away from the transatlantic
planes she must be bursting with every
distraction imaginable they want
first-class spas they want variety of
food and beverage outlets they want all
the amenities of a first-class resort
which creates a problem the maximum size
of the ship's design is limited by the
dimensions of three passages she will
sail through she can be no higher than
the verrazano-narrows bridge in New York
no longer than the turning area near
Southampton and no wider than the Panama
Canal
owner Micky Arison then raises the bar
even higher he insists over half his
passengers must have their own private
balcony space I can remember the first
meeting I had with the naval architects
when they told me that on a
transatlantic liner you can't have any
balcony cabins and my answer was if we
can't have any Malkin cabins we can't
have a transatlantic liner and they said
okay we'll go back to the drawing board
to create enough space
despite the three design constraints
Stephen Payne must transform the rules
of shipbuilding every time I met Mick
garrison he would ask me how many more
balcony cabins have you managed to
squeeze into the design of the ship pane
experiments with increasing the ship's
height to fit in enough cabins and
balconies but this makes the ship
dangerously unstable for every ton of
weight on top there must be two tons
below to balance it out her sister ship
the qe2
solves this problem by using aluminium
for her upper decks which is lighter
than steel but this is no longer an
option
after 30 years aluminium suffers metal
fatigue and the qe2 now needs frequent
repairs Payne's design must last longer
the challenge is so great the project
nearly collapses twice we were put on
hold because the economics are building
the ship just didn't seem to work but
Miki insists a solution be found
eventually Paine and his team make a
proposal to build a ship that's longer
and wider than ever before to
accommodate enough passengers this
enormous stable base means they can
increase the height and still use steel
for the structure but her beam must be
far wider than planned
breaking the initial ground rules the
ship had to be large enough to meet the
demands of our guests and the end and
clearly could not be built to to go
through the Panama Canal
this decision comes at a heavy price
during special round-the-world voyages
the qm2 will be forced to travel via
South America instead a 15,000 kilometer
voyage which takes her round Cape Horn
one of the most dangerous passages on
the planet
but Mickey gets his balconies